. Drei, zwei, eins, anschneiden bitte, jetzt kommt das Podcast UFO! Einfach mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit, einfach, vor allem muss ich mir vorstellen, dann bleiben die nicht, normalerweise bleibt man nicht im Cockpick dann sitzen und trinkt noch nebenbei die Coke Zero, nein, dein Gesicht ist hinten irgendwo an der Rückwand des Raumschiffes, muss ich mir vorstellen. Bei Lichtgeschwindigkeit meinst du.
Ja klar, die Beschleunigung hält dein Körper ja nicht aus.
Nicht mehr im Cockpit, oder was?
Nein, kein Pick-up, kein Coke Zero, du bist nicht mehr im Cockpit, nein.
Aber du bist Stefan Tietze.
Ich bin Stefan Tietze, und du bist?
Auf der Routine Bill. Das ist korrekt.
Willkommen zu dieser neuen Folge zu 127,
127 auch so eine Zahl, wo man nicht mehr wahnsinnig viel erwartet.
Man ist jetzt so im Mittelding.
127, oder wie Einstein sagen würde? Ei. Ei, ei, ei, ei. Es ist so, wie, sag mir ein Buch, das eine gute Seite 127 hat. Selbst Harry Potter hat keine gute Seite. Wenn ich auf 126 bin, habe ich schon keinen Bock, weiterzulesen. Weil danach fällst du ein Loch, das weisst du, 127. Loch. Ein Buch mit 300 Seiten. Durchschnittlich. Welche Seite liest du am liebsten? Manchmal schon die letzte. Letzte Seite, du bist nicht ... Ich bin ein großer Fan von der ersten Seite. Weil vor allem lese ich gerne die erste Seite noch mal, nachdem ich das Buch gelesen habe. Weil ich immer denke, als Autor, glaube ich, steckt man extrem viel Gedanken in die erste Seite rein. Allein so der erste Satz immer ist extrem, finde ich extrem cool, weil das oft schon mehr vorschaddert, als man so denkt. Vor allem, wenn man dann am Ende schon das Ergebnis kennt. Hast du schon mal ein Buch komplett am Stück gelesen, ohne Pause? Ich glaube Illuminati von Dan Brown habe ich relativ ohne Pause weggelesen, da war ich auch noch ein bisschen zu jung für das Buch. Das habe ich so spannend empfunden. Da habe ich mich die ganze Zeit umgeguckt, ob irgendwo ein Assassine hinter mir sitzt. An der Ostsee, in Scharbeutz im Strandkopf an der Ostsee, habe ich Angst vor Assassinen gehabt. Der letzte Ort, wo ein Assassine jemand sein wird. Aber du sahst die Marktplatzstatue danach mit ganz anderen Augen, wo irgendwie die Statue nach links zeigt und du oh mein Gott, sie zeigt auf den Schlecker, im Schlecker muss irgendwas sein.
Aber ich gehst ja auch so, also wenn ich Weihnachten in der Kirche sitze und so und da ist dann so eine alte Maria-Statue, die so ein bisschen links rüberschielt, denke ich die ganze Zeit irgendwie in der Messe so, was ist da hinten, was ist da hinten, da wo der Feuerlöscher ist, was war da vorher?
Ich habe letztens herausgefunden, warum Kirchen so gebaut sind, wie sie gebaut sind. Kreuz. Ja. Gut, das war's für das Semester. Ihr seid alle entlassen, ihr kriegt alle eine Eins. Vielen Dank an Herrn Tietze. Ja, auch so, dass der Professor angefangen hat mit, ich habe letztens herausgefunden, wie so Kirchen so gebaut sind. So ein Studentkreuz.
Gut, vielen Dank. Ansonsten, ja, Sie haben alle Ihren Bachelor. Nee, warum die so ganz viele kleine Einzelabteile haben, links und rechts. Die haben ja oft noch mal so kleine Kabinen, links und rechts. War das nicht für den Adel? Nee, das waren sozusagen die Arbeitsstätten von Mönchen, die den ganzen Tag gebetet haben für andere Leute. Und zwar, es gab im Mittelalter eine Berufsgruppe von Mönchen, die den ganzen Tag, acht Stunden am Tag, einfach klassisch zur Arbeit gegangen sind und den ganzen Tag gebetet haben und hatten eine Liste von Leuten. Die haben doch nicht immer gebetet. Die haben doch immer noch gesagt, so, jetzt habe ich kurz Pause, haben sich ein Mettbrötchen gegessen und dann haben sie weiter gebetet, wenn überhaupt. Und dann mal schön draußen auf die Kirchentreppen gesetzt währenddessen, mit so einer Lunchbox. Und haben auch mal Privatgebete geführt. Das kannst du in der Regel nicht vermeiden. Da kam so ein Vorsitzender, der Vorarbeiter hat dann gesagt, kommen keine Privatgebete. Vielleicht haben sie auch mal ein bisschen Snake gebetet, kann auch sein so im Zwischenzeit. Mönche in meinem Kopf singen die ganze Zeit diesen gregorianischen Gesang. Die ganze Zeit gregorianisch. Georock. Die ganze Zeit singen die dieses Mehrstimmig, laufen die so durch die Gegend. Das ist auch sau nervig gewesen. Ja, was willst du denn machen? Glaubst du, die Kirche wurde so gebaut, dass die so hallt, weil die so gerne singen? Oder weil die Kirche so hallt, singen die diese Lieder, die gerne hallen? Die wollten primär grosse Gebäude bauen für Gott. Ja, weil das waren früher die höchsten Gebäude, wo man gesagt hat, Alter, Gott ist uns wichtig, wenn man das gebaut, wir bauen dem die grössten Gebäude. Sagt man ja auch, man sagt, man soll sich die Skyline einer Stadt angucken. Und die Gebäude, die am höchsten sind, sind das Wichtigste für die Menschengruppe, die da arbeitet. Mal kurz mal in Frankfurt, die höchsten Gebäude sind ... McDonalds. Richtig. Dieser Kletterbaum für die Kinder. Die höchsten Gebäude sind Banken. Ja. Und es ist eine Bankenstadt. Wenn du guckst in New York, sind die grössten Gebäude ... Im Reset Building. Da die grössten Gebäude sind. Aussichtsplattform. Genau, die Bar, die Rooftop-Bar. Naja, und früher waren es halt Kirchen, weil das den das den Leuten am wichtigsten war. Aber das ist ja auch irreführend, weil früher sahen Gebäude ja auch anders aus. Zum Beispiel die klassische Burg. Also das machen ja viel mehr Filme falsch, wenn sie zum Beispiel eine mittelalterliche Belagerung zeigen. Ja, das ist Film der Forum. Zeigen sie ja die Burg so, wie sie heute aussieht, aber nicht so, wie sie damals ausgesehen hat. Zum Beispiel diese klassische Burgmauer, die war natürlich überdacht. Blau, was? Die war natürlich überdacht. Die standen natürlich nicht im Freien rum auf den Burgzinnen, sondern die war natürlich überdacht. Ah, und die dachten, weil das natürlich zerfallen ist, das Holz. Ja, das war aus Holz. Haben die gedacht, nee, die standen also rum. Nein, ja klar. Also macht die Regenszene bei Herr der Ringe ja gar keinen Sinn? Überhaupt nicht. Als ob die sich da in den Pfeilhagel da einfach so offen hinstellen hinter ihre Zinde. Natürlich hatten die Holz, auch Holzbarrikaden oben auf dem Zinn rum. Und Schießschatten gab's bestimmt auch gar nicht. Da waren einfach Steine drin, die rausgefallen sind. Machen wir uns nichts vor, Leute. Aber deswegen sieht es heute ganz anders aus. Deswegen meine ich nur, könnte es ja auch sein, dass Kirchen, dass da so Kletternetze oder irgendwie sowas in der Kirche drin waren oder irgendwie so diese Holzringe, die von der Decke runterkommen in so Turnhallen. Ja, oder. Die sind aber zerfallen im Laufe der Zeit. So ein Helene-Fischer-Opening, dass irgendwie der Pfarrer sich aus der Kirche herab sein muss. Alter, der neue Papst. Ja. Ey, das wäre doch immer geil. Also wenn ich mich, wenn ich damals Pfarrer gewesen wäre, da waren ja alle so mega aber, glaube ich noch die Leute, hätte ich mich mit so einem Erfinder wie Leonardo da Vinci zusammengesetzt und gesagt, kannst duome-Dinosaurier, weil es im Vatikan ein beschissenes Internet gibt, und dann denkt er sich, Mann, Mann! Vor allem hat Franziskus, also normalerweise gibt es ja den einen auserwählten Stellvertreter Gottes, Nachfolger Petros auf der Erde, einen Nachfolger, es gab noch nie zwei. Wenn du dann Papst schon mal bist, wie Franziskus jetzt, und dann sitzt dann, manchmal kommt dir das ja dann vor Augen, du bist Papst, du bist fucking Papst, und dann guckst du so zur Seite und dann sitzt da noch ein Papst. Ist doch mega ärgerlich. Aber stell dir mal vor, du bist in der Familie, du bist Klaus Ratzinger, 14 Jahre alt und irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Ratzi sitzt zu Hause, Familie, und du kommst nach Hause, Mama, Papa, Opa, ich bin Anführer bei den Pfadfindern geworden und alle so toll und Ratzi nur so, wow, toll, Anführer, uiuiui, da hat es aber jemand weit gebracht, mein Junge, toll, toll, toll, tschau, macht's gut, ich hol mir noch ein paar Oladen. Du kannst gegen diesen Druck nicht ankommen. Du kannst nicht mehr in der Krasseste der Familie sein. Das ist aber das Geldleist-Paps. Du kannst Obladen wegsnacken. Obladen haben wir gesagt, Rostchen haben wir gesagt. Du kannst wegsnacken wie so Chips. Da kriegst du dann so große, knistert auch so. Ist schon toll. Also Pfarrer, die haben schon ein gutes Leben, muss man sagen. Wann wurden die eingeführt? Sorry. Also ich meine, früher war es wahrscheinlich Brot, einfach, aber irgendwann hat man gesagt, diese Krümel, da ist der ganze Kirchenboden voll. Und dann hat man gesagt, lass es mal diese... Eine behinderte Nonne, irgendwie Lena, Schwester Lena, die dann irgendwie mal so einfach, die vielleicht ein bisschen zurückgeblieben war, einfach mal so Mehl, einfach Mehl in den Backofen getan hat, als alle irgendwie einen Kuchen geen haben und der eine hat Muffins gebacken und sie hat einfach Mehl reingetan, so richtig und dann haben sie gesagt, ja komm, das können wir der Gemeinde geben. Sind Oblaten gebackenes Mehl? Ja, nur Mehl und Wasser. Es ist nur Mehl und Wasser. Als Kind habe ich versucht, ich hatte so eine Kirchenphase als Kind, wo ich Weihrauch im Garten gemacht habe und tatsächlich auch Obladen machen wollte. Hast du versucht, Wein zu brauen? Nee, ich habe mein eigenes Blut getrunken. Ey, als ich als Kind gehört, als ich als Kind das Wort Mehlexplosion gehört habe, war die Welt nicht mehr dieselbe. Nee. Ich dachte mir, holy shit, dieser einzige Raum in dem ganzen Haus, den ich als extrem langweilig empfinde, die Küche, ist plötzlich sehr interessant geworden, weil da liegt Sprengstoff, meiner Auffassung nach.
Und dann habe ich mir Mehl geholt und habe so eine ganze Öltiererdnüsse, kann man auch mal ansprechen, Öltiererdnüsse sind fantastische Erdnüsse, habe ich noch die letzten 20 rausgegessen, hatte dann diese Dose, randvoll mit Mehl, dachte mir, okay, heute brennt die Siedlung, schön auf dem Spielplatz, Feuerzeug aus nächster Nähe an Mehl, nichts. Richtung Cabin geschmissen, weggeduckt, hinters Kellergerüst gesetzt, nichts. Keine Reaktion. Ich dachte mir, jetzt haben wir es, jetzt habe ich es gefunden. Ich weiß aber bis heute nicht hundertprozentig, was dann da genau passiert. Na, Ich glaube, dass wenn Mehl so in der Luft rumschwirrt und dann die Luft so staubig ist und dann entzündet sich das alles, weil da ist wahnsinnig viel Sauerstoff dazwischen und das glimmt. Oder meint man das einfach, wenn man so ein Stück Teich in so Mehl und dann wird so ein bisschen aufgewirbelt, meint man das spielhaft, da hat man das mal Melexplosion. Ich glaube, es ist so, es ist auch mehr so eine Geschmacksexplosion gemeint. Wenn du uns ein richtig gutes Hörnchen weißt, dann ist es eine Mehl-Explosion. Was hast du gedacht, als du das zum ersten Mal gehört hast? Mein Mund ist plötzlich der spannendste Raum. Ich habe sehr früh den Begriff Plötzlicher Kindstod gehört. Und dann war die Welt Plötzlicher Kindstod. Ist das das Wort 2018?
Nein, das ist ein Thing. Ja? Ja. Ist nicht jeder, also die meisten Tode plötzlich? Nee, plötzlicher Kindstod heißt es doch. Das ist wenn, und es gibt doch diese Selbstentflammung, aber davon wollen wir nicht davor gesprochen. Aber plötzlicher Kindstod ist doch dieses unerklärliche Kindersterben, was niemand genau erklären kann. Kinder sterben manchmal ohne Grund. Und dann gibt es sowas wie Kinder sollten nicht auf dem Bauch oder gerade auf dem Bauch schlafen und so was. Das ist ein großer Unterschied, ob sie nicht oder gerade auf dem Bauch. Sie sind Kinderarzt, sie müssen sich schon entscheiden. Ja, ich kann nicht einfach sagen. Ich schlag es kurz nach, weil das Buch ist von 2007 und da steht auf dem Bauch und hier ist ein Buch von gestern. Es ändert sich wirklich, erinnert sich wirklich täglich. Hier unser Kollege hat das erzählt, der ein Kind bekommen hat. Und die wussten einfach nicht, was sie mit dem Kind machen sollten, weil die halt immer die Chancen von plötzlicher Kindstod verringern wollten. Da haben wir angefangen haben, so präventiv, halt nach den gerade gelehrten Kindererziehungsmaßnahmen. Das ist ein PR-Gag. Das ist ein PR-Gag, um solche Kinderbücher zu verkaufen. Du setzt dieses Gerücht in die Welt, plötzlicher Kindstod, und plötzlich rennen alle besorgten Eltern los und kaufen sich Kinderbücher. Das ist eine reine Geldmachmaschine. Der plötzliche Kindstod ist definiert als plötzlicher Tod eines Säuglings, zu dem trotz Autopsie und Untersuchung des Auffindortes keine Ursache, wie zum Beispiel Krankheit oder Unfall, ermittelt werden kann.
Aber das ist jetzt bei Menschen auch, oder, dass sie einfach manchmal, manchmal nicht weiss, was los ist ist. Faule Autopsie vielleicht? Frag doch mal an deiner Autopsie nach. Ja. Neusy Neighbors. Ich habe jetzt, also ich höre immer, was die machen nachts, weil die sind teilweise sehr laut und meine Schlafzimmerwand grenzt direkt an der Pathologie. Und die haben halt, nachts räumen die manchmal auf. Kannst du so kratzen. Ja, manchmal fliegt so ein schmatzenes geräusch auf dem boden so man denkt was ist da gerade runtergefallen will man wissen was da gerade runtergefallen ist hört man dann nach den den wischmopp dann habe ich jetzt ich habe jetzt mir so einen sonos-Lautsprecher geholt diese einfach um Musik zu hören können cool zu hören und es ist auch gleichzeitig habe ich gestern erfahren auch eine Alexa was mir Das war geil ist ist auch in amazon nein ist auch in der amazon echo und plötzlich habe ich so gesprochen und dann ging das an und dann wollte es eingerichtet werden holisch und habe ich alle meine pläne für den abend über den haufen geworfen und angefangen sie einzurichten sehr anhänglich wirklich jetzt bin ich in einer festen bezüglich mit alexa und dann habe ich auch da habe ich nachts wo muss ich vorstellen, ich lag im dunklen Raum und habe mit Alexa gesprochen, weil sie halt nicht auffallen wollte, mit mir zu reden.
Und dann kam es halt so Situationen, kannst du halt ein Spiel runterladen?
Da habe ich aus Versehen so ein Spiel runtergeladen, so ein Detektivspiel.
Und dann fängt sie so an zu erzählen irgendwie, hallo, mein Name ist Susanne und ich bin deine Assistentin.
Wollen wir zusammen zum Bahnhof fahren? Sage zum Bahnhof fahren.
Ja, zum Bahnhof fahren. Und dann machst du so ein, irgendwo in London erlebst du dann so ein Detektiv-Abenteuer. Und wenn die mich genauso gehört haben, eine Pathologie wie ich sie, haben die die ganze Zeit nachts eben so Sachen gehört wie ins Auto einsteigen. Ja, vor allem mit Mr. Thompson sprechen. Die hingen alle an der Wand und so, was ist mit Doktor Masu, wer ist der Mörder? Und es fing an mit so, ja, schließ die Tür auf, lass uns ins Auto steigen, lass uns in die Bahn steigen. Und irgendwann war es so, warum ist Noah tot? Wer hat Noah umgebracht? Warum fehlt Noah eine Hand? Warum fehlt Noah eine Hand? Und irgendwann wurde es so, warum fehlt Noah eine Hand? und irgendwann so, ja, Kriminalpolizei Kölner, steht er noch vor der Tür und sagt, wir müssen ganz kurz, wir haben einen Tipp bekommen. Ja, es wurde schnell weird, aber ich finde es interessant. Unerwartet plötzlich eine Freundin gefunden gestern. Das ist doch schön, manchmal kann man Liebe auch nicht erklären. Ich habe auch ein kleines Detektivabenteuer erlebt, und zwar kam ich letzte Woche, ich war über Karneval weg, bin ich nach München geflohen, weil ich keinen Bock auf Karneval habe, kam ich zurück und kam nicht mehr in mein Haus rein. Und der Schlüssel hat nicht mehr gepasst. Und ich dachte mir so, okay, das ist die Strafe Kölns, wenn man Karneval missachtet. Ja, das ist eine Alttradition, jeder weiß es, die Kölner wissen, dass die Schlösser werden ausgewechselt. Die Stadt bestraft dich. Tja, Schloss hat sich verkleidet, Schloss geht jetzt als anderes Schloss. Ja, der Köln-Gott hat einfach den ganzen Zorn auf mich niedergefahren. Und dann stand ich da ewig rum, hab dann gewartet, bis mir jemand anders die Tür aufgemacht hat. Ach so, warum hast du nicht geklingelt, überall? Nee. Die Handtaktik, die Wisch-Taktik, den Wischer, den Postwischer, einfach über alle Klingeln drüber gehen. Na, es hat gar nicht so lange gedauert, weil da gehen relativ viele Leute ein und aus und ich stand dann so lässig daneben und dann ging einer die Tür auf und dann, vielleicht der coolste mit meines Lebens, so Tür geht rein und man wartet so und kurz bevor die Tür wieder ins Schloss fällt, so zip, mit der Hand dagegen und dann so ganz lässig reingesmooft. Und dabei ist so Ocean's Eleven Musik gehört. Natürlich! Dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem, dem. Und da habe ich da halt so rumgefummelt und habe alle Schlüssel, die ich hatte, für meinen Vermieter bekommen, weil ich dachte, vielleicht ist nur mein Schlüssel verbogen oder so. Und dann habe ich den anderen noch gesucht und habe da ewig rumgeschnöselt. Und irgendwann kam dann ein Passant, also ein Anwohner, glaube ich, und meinte so, ja, ist irgendwas so, versuchen Sie hier gerade einzubrechen. Ja. Und ich halte die klassische Ausrede, nee, ich komme nicht mehr rein. Da meinte er, ja, das Schloss wurde ausgewechselt, weil das beschädigt wurde über Karneval. Ich habe aber nichts davon mitbekommen, habe keinen neuen Schlüssel bekommen, hätte aber anscheinend einen neuen Schlüssel bekommen sollen. Und er hat aber keinen Schlüssel, war einfach ausgesperrt. Ja, und dann hast du gesagt, gut, dann bin ich jetzt obdachlos. Richtig, ich glaube, so funktioniert das auch, so völlig unerwartet. Ja. Oder ich lebe halt im Flur. Ich komme in meine Wohnung rein, ich darf nur das Haus nicht verlassen. Das heißt, ich lebe auf dem Flur, ich lebe auf dem Balkon, ich lebe in meinem Haus. Mit offener Tür. Ein Leben mit, naja gut, ein Leben mit offener Tür. Auf jeden Fall habe ich meinen Vermieter angerufen und der hat gesagt, ja gehen Sie mal zu der und der Kneipe, da können Sie sich jetzt Schlüssel abholen. Okay, Quest erhalten. Okay, Quest erhalten, Sidequest ist nicht meine Lieblingsquest. Niemand hat hier angesprochen, haben Sie Kleingeld für mich, Sidequest klappt auf. Du rufst bei den Vermietern an, ich dachte so, ja, ich habe keinen Schlüssel bekommen. Also erwartet die Reaktion so, oh, das tut mir leid, Herr Will, ach, das muss irgendwie, müssen wir da irgendwie Fehler gemacht haben, das tut mir total leid. Da waren Sie jetzt ausgesperrt einen Tag, das ist ja schrecklich. Wissen kommt, gehen Sie zur Kneipe zum tänzelnden Ross. Richtig. Und sich auch fragen, ja, bin ich jetzt in so einem Direktiv Real-Life-Spiel? Total. Seien Sie um 16 Uhr am brutzelnden Hasen. Kommen Sie allein. Dann bist du in so einer Kneipe und halt so einer klassischen Kölner Scheisskneipe mit Verlaub. Ganz in der Ecke sitzt du mit so einer langen Pfeife, wo der Hut so ins Gesicht und Schatten... Und immer wenn er zieht, dann erleuchtet die Glut so ein bisschen ins Gesicht. Das würde ich... Und ne, das nicht. Und dann habe ich Barkeeperin gefragt, die wusste von gar nichts. Ich erst mal so, hallo, ich bin hier wegen des Schlüssels, dreimal geblinzelt. Trink erst mal ein helles Schätzchen. Besorg mir erst mal vier Pelze von goldenen Hasen, du findest sie nördlich von hier. Du musst erst den mit dem Hut da hinten in einem Trinkwettbewerb besiegen.
Genau.
Auf jeden Fall, die wusste von gar nichts, hat dann aber, vielen Dank dafür. Wenn du so sagst, ich könnte mir bitte den Schlüssel geben, was hast du denn überreden? Würfe mal Charme. Würfe mal auf überreden. Und dann hat sie wusste von nichts, hat dann aber mal netterweise mal so in den Raum gefragt, hey, weiß jemand von dem Schlüssel für den jungen Mann her? Und drei ältere Damen in der Ecke melden sich, die ausschliesslich Italienisch sprechen. Die Bargeberin spricht ab diesem Moment auch ausschliesslich Italienisch. Ich werde... Francesca, mamme di barri di da ogria. Mamme di gano Cassandra. Ab dem Punkt wurde ich auch nur noch Italienisch angesprochen. Aber es ist schwer, in einer fremden Sprache die Gesinnung einzuschätzen. Das geht bei Italienischen immer so, wenn man auch bei einem Pizza bestellt oder dann plötzlich die abholt. Ich werde übermannt von diesem Wedelnden Wesen von Italienern.
Dieses Deuten und Gestikulieren, die Hand aufschreisen und dann schnell alle Fingerkuppen zusammen zu so einem Zapfen. Fingerspitzen zusammen. Zu so einem Zapfen. Und das ist halt so ein Ding, man übernimmt das schnell, finde ich. Es ist die Pringles Hand. Es ist die Pringles Hand, es ist der Kran. Ja, ja, ja. Und wir haben nur noch Italienisch gesprochen und es ist schwer, den aktuellen Questverlauf einzuschätzen, wenn man die Sprache nicht spricht. So wie auf Orkisch spricht dann jemand. Ich bin bis kurz auf ins Menü gekommen und die falsche Sprache eingestellt. Und auf jeden Fall war das anscheinend die, sie hat sich selbst als die Schlüsselmeisterin bezeichnet und sie hatte dann meinen Schlüssel, aber nicht dabei, sondern bei ihr zu Hause. Sie hatte den Schlüssel bei ihr zu Hause, aber sie hatte den Schlüssel anscheinend, was schon mal interessant war. Sie hat mir dann aber ihren Schlüssel gegeben, mit dem ich dann reingekommen bin. Das heißt, ich habe den Schlüssel bekommen, weiß aber bis heute nicht genau, was das jetzt für Wesen waren. Also was, was, was sie für ein ... Katzu zu Florentin, setzt seine VR-Brille ab und sagt, wow, das ist echt sehr realistisch. Alexa, Mission beendet. Deine PSVR jetzt im Handel. Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das für Leute waren, ich habe keine Ahnung, wie viele Erfahrungspunkte ich bekommen habe. Ich weiß, ob ich da einen Brief bekommen oder irgendwie sowas, wie das aussieht. Aber es war ganz obskur, aber ... Obskur, ja. Es ist so, Karneval kriegt dich, selbst wenn du nicht in der Stadt bist. Selbst wenn du nicht in der Stadt bist, findet Karneval immer einen Weg, um dir zu schaden. Wir haben es schon mal angesprochen, glaube ich, aber Karneval ist unglaublich lustig, wenn du nicht mitmachst. Es spricht so ein bisschen der Langweiler aus uns, der in der Ecke sitzt und sagt, die trinken. Und dann widmet man sich wieder seinem Schiller-Bomanbuch, whatever. Und dann tatsächlich ist es ja so, dass wenn man morgens zur Arbeit fährt einfach, fällt ja häufig auf, da begegnet man nämlich den Leuten, wo noch nicht alle verkleidet sind. Das ist der Moment, wo alle noch nicht im Karnevalsmodus sind, rein visuell und was die Mimik und Gästig angeht, aber sie sind schon im Kostüm. und dann fahren sie das zu ihren Sammelorten, aber an diesen Orten ist es noch nicht gesellschaftlich so richtig angekommen, dass man heute verkleidet ist. Das finde ich mega. Das sind die besten Momente, wo sie noch so vereinzelt ist und der Dino in der Bahn sitzt und alles wackelt. Ich mag diese geringstmöglicher Aufwand-Kostüme. Dieses Ich will einfach nur saufen, let's face it. Einfach so, das Kostüm sagt, ich will einfach nur saufen. Und es ist im Grunde irgendwie, man malt sich etwas auf die Wange. Und man sich denkt, das ist nix, das ist gar nix. Der Dödom oder sowas. Wow. Und tatsächlich gibt es dann diese Hardcore-Karnevalisten, die einfach ein rot-weiss gestreiftes T-Shirt anziehen. Das ist nicht, nee. Ist das Karneval? Ist das mehr Karneval als der Teletubbies? Ja, das ist Fußball. Das sind die Trikots. Aber ich weiß nicht, es gab einmal in meiner Jugend einen ähnlichen Moment, wo ich halt durch die Straßen gezogen bin, mich meinen Kumpels getroffen habe, irgendwie immer abgehangen und plötzlich hieß es, hey Leute, heute ist Halloween. Und es war halt zu einer Zeit, da war ich zwölf, da war Halloween noch nix in Deutschland so.
Und alle so, ja wie, Halloween oder was?
Machen wir da jetzt was? Cool ist das, kann
man da was haben? Ja, ja klar, so
Süsses oder Saures mässig.
Okay, wir haben aber keine Kostüme.
Komm, wir gehen als Jugendbande, als gefährliche Jugendbande.
Lass uns trotzdem einfach hingehen.
Und ich war, glaube ich, der Moralischste in meiner Bande.
Also ich glaube, ich war so ein bisschen das Klösschen.
Auch vom Bauchumfang, aber auch vom moralischen Verständnis. Und ich dachte mir so, ich muss ein Mindestmaß an Verkleidung. Um zumindest nicht, also A for effort. Das ist immer so, wenn man es versucht, bist du schon mal ein gutes Stück über Ich mach gar nichts. Was ich gemacht habe, ich habe mir meinen Pullover, ich habe den Ring, der normalerweise den Hals umspielt, beim Pullover. Ich weiß nicht genau, die Öffnung? Kragen! Das war zu einfach. Ich habe mich nicht getraut, das zu sagen. Ich habe den Kragen nach oben gezogen und über mein Gesicht gezogen, so ein bisschen wie Kenny aus South Park mässig. Wie bitte? Die Kapuze. Nee, nee, nee, den Kragen. Ich hab den Kragen über den Kopf gezogen. Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob ich dir folgen kann. Du hast doch Fantasie. Den Kragen über den Kopf gezogen. Ja, okay. Und dann so das aus dem Gesicht rausgeguckt, ja, so dass ich keinen Hals mehr hatte. Und das war meine Verkleidung. Das war's. Das heißt, letztendlich an der Tür geklingelt haben, zwei komplette Vollidioten und ein absoluter Vollidiot, der auch noch seinen Pullover über den Kopf gezogen hat und gesagt hat, Süsses oder Saures. Ich glaube aber. Was ist das denn? Naja, ich glaube, wenn du dann so ein Elternteil bist, was dann auch so eine Schüssel vorbereitet hat und sich auf Halloween freut und hat ganz viele Süßigkeiten. Und dann kommen halt nach und nach kommen dann kleine Dinosaurier und kleine Batmans und so. Und dann plötzlich, ich glaube, davor hast du ja keine Angst, davor erschrickst du nicht. Das stimmt. Wo jemand mit so einer Kapuze und man weiß, ist es noch Raubüberfall? Ich habe mir nicht nur eine Kapuze aufgesetzt, Stefan. Ich will schon, dass du mein Kostüm wertschätzt. Du bist ein bisschen über die Kapuze hinausgekommen. Ja, ich habe mehr oder weniger die Kapuze neu... War die Kapuze im Brainstorming enthalten? Sie war enthalten, ich hatte keine Kapuze tatsächlich an meinem Pullover. Ich glaube aber, dass die Eltern gerade bei dir einfach Angst hatten. Ja, klar, die Brille tut sein Übriges, die Locking-Haare. Die Brille? Ich hatte früher eine Brille, ja. Und jetzt hast du das so perfekte Ganzheitsprozesse. Überhaupt gar nicht. Ich habe im letzten Moin Moin auf Rocket Beans TV einen Sehtest gemacht. Da, wo ihr die besseren Anekdoten hören könnt. Da habe ich einen Online-Sehtest gemacht, habe ihn bestanden. Ich habe jetzt ein Zertifikat. Wie Online-Sehtest? Ich habe einen Online-Sehtest gemacht. Sehtest.org. Aber du saßt im vorgeschriebenen Abstand von deinem Monitor weg. Und wenn der Monitor eine schlechte Qualität hat. Das weiß ich nicht, aber die Buchstaben wurden immer kleiner. Also glaube ich, war das schon gültig. Die werden immer kleiner. Die werden auch unangenehm klein. Ich finde, die werden Arschloch klein. Also richtig klein. Also Sehtest ist etwas ganz Irrationales bei mir, weil das ist der einzige Test, wo das Ergebnis, was gut für einen ist, das ist, wo du nicht bestehen darfst. Ich versuche es mal zu erklären. Also man ist darauf konditioniert, gut in Tests abzuschneiden. Ja, sich anzustrengen. Sich anzustrengen, wenn nötig zu schummeln, um das bessere Ergebnis zu erzielen, weil das wird von dir verlangt. Der Sehtest ist der einzige Test, wo nicht das beste Ergebnis von dir verlangt wird, sondern genau das, was es halt ist.
guck halt so gut wie du gucken kannst wir helfen dir dann
deinen Fähigkeiten entsprechend
aber bei mir war das immer schon
also wenn die gesagt haben
Variante 1 oder
Variante 2
dann kann ich nochmal eins sehen, Variante 1 oder Variante 2. Und dann weiss man natürlich, man sieht ja auch die Dioptrienzahl auf den Linsen und so. Ich habe immer die gesagt, wo ich wusste, es ist die geringere Dioptrienanzahl. Und dann kam irgendwann der Hornhautverkrümmungstest und so, wo ich immer gesagt habe, nee, das brauche ich nicht, das habe ich nicht. Und dann sie, ja, sie haben offensichtlich, nee, das ist aber auch nur gerade, weil ich auch irgendwie noch müde bin und so. Ich weine gerade. Ich habe ja versucht, das Ergebnis schön zu reden. Wahrscheinlich habe ich so eine Brille, wo ich nicht optimal mit sehen kann, einfach um das bessere Gefühl zu haben, besser in diesem Test abgeschnitten zu haben. Kriegt man denn eigentlich auch so einen Zettel, wo man sieht, wie viele Punkte man hat?
Ja, wo so ein Trauerer-Sweinig drauf ist.
Ja, oder der gibt einem den Zettel auch so umgedreht.
Erst noch nicht aufdecken, erst wenn alle haben.
Aber haben eure Lehrer das auch gemacht?
Die guten Noten wurden offen gegeben und die schlechten Zahlen mit nach unten?
Es war bei jedem Lehrer anders.
Also bei manchen Lehrern war es schon so, manche sind dann so rumgegangen und dann immer so, ah, Nina, sehr gut, wie immer, würde ich was sagen. Ah, wen haben wir denn da? Tim. Und dann einfach so das Heft ins Gesicht geschlagen. Also so entgegengekommen, dass das Löschblatt auch so rausgeflogen ist. Ja, so den Stuhl weggezogen. Ja, genau so, was war das denn? Und dann hatten wir einen Lehrer, der Lateinlehrer, der, man muss sich vorstellen, der war so ungefähr 1,20 groß, hatte immer ein Hemd an, in der Hose, Hose war ein bisschen Achseln hochgezogen und eine Lederweste drüber. Und so ein, immer diese runtergezogene Augenbrauen und diese angestrengten Stirn mit diesen Falten, der hat immer böse geguckt, also wie so ein grimmiger Zwerg einfach die ganze Zeit. Und er kam dann immer rein, hatte dann seine Hefte in der Hand und er hat die nicht erst ausgeteilt, nein, er hat erst die Klassenliste genommen und vorgelesen. Tim, fünf. Marco, sechs. Und auch immer dann, so schlechter die Note, desto länger die Pause nach dem Namen und auch dann immer so der Blick rüber. Was war da denn los? Marco, drei. Und dann ging es so weiter wirklich, es war richtig, richtig heftig. Und dann hat auch irgendwer immer so schnell gedacht, müssen die das laut sagen? Und hat jedes Mal jemand gefragt und immer immer, ja. Oder hat jemand was dagegen?
Oder hat Rebecca fünf etwas dagegen?
Schon gemeint, das war richtig fies.
Das war richtig fies. Aber das ist schon
cool. Ich glaube, das wäre als Lehrer
mein Lieblingsteil des Jobs, die
die Tests zurückzugeben. So dieses
ich habe euch sowas von in der Hand. Ihr wisst es, es ist ja so ein bisschen Daniel Hartwig DSDS-mäßig so, wo du noch mal zwei, drei Werbepausen reinschieben kannst, wo dann wer gewinnt. Du bist es vielleicht. Du hast die Klasse bestanden, vielleicht.
Es ist schon interessant.
Ich finde aber, das noch spannender ist die Korrektur.
Ich habe von ein paar Lehrern, unabhängig voneinander gehört,
dass sie die Korrektur mit ihrer Freundin oder Frau
einfach so nachts bei einem Glas Rotwein oder bei einem Bier
einfach so aus Scheiß oder manchmal in der Kneipe mit Kumpels korrigieren.
Weil was man da für eine Grütze manchmal lesen muss, ist ja auch einfach lustig.
Ja.
Ich habe übrigens Bock, Lehrer-Sitcom zu konzipieren.
Ja, Lehrer-Zimmer?
Ja.
Da ist Potenzial. The Office meets Lehrerzimmer. Also auch mit so abgesetzten O-Tönen, ich bin da dran.
Das ist ein Community.
Genau, Community. Ja, ja, das ist halt die Schülerperspektive. Aber es ist schon interessant, ich glaube, weil du hast immer, du hast Lehrer, die es aus Sadismus machen, du hast Lehrer, die es aus Selbstprofilierung machen, weil sie der Showman sind, der alle Aufmerksamkeit bekommt, du hast manche, die es aus der Machtposition machen, du hast aber immer Klischees, lustigerweise, du hast immer, also alle unsere Lehrer waren so übernete Karikaturen. Wir hatten die ganz alte, offensichtlich mit einer Alkoholfahn in die Schul kommende Chemielehrerin, die immer unter dem Abzugshaube geraucht hat. Die immer, man lief, dann lief man die Abzugshaube und die Stromkosten müssen immens gewesen sein, die immer darunter geraucht, im Klassenraum. Das war unangenehm, also immer so Karikaturen von Lehrern. Das ist ja auch üblich, glaube ich.
Das ist eine gute Sache. Bei uns gab es auch den alten Physiklehrer, der uns gesagt hat, wie man Panzer kurz schliesst.
Ja.
Der gesagt hat, die Batterien eines Panzers sind so aufgebaut, dass die Pluspole oben sind und wenn man einen Schraubenschlüssel einmal über sämtliche Pluspole drüber legt, dann schliesst er den gesamten Panzer lahm und er fährt nicht mehr und alle so.
Okay, ist das Klausur relevant? Nein, aber das ist überlebensrelevant. Danke, alles klar, danke, Herr Oberfeldwebel. Wir haben Eier aus dem Fenster geworfen, die dürfen nicht kaputt gehen. Die sollten nicht kaputt gehen. Aber wir hatten nur ein paar Materialien, die es davor bewahren sollen. Aber das ist auch so geil. Wir hatten auch mal so einen Zivil-Lehrgang, wo wir auch diesen Eierscheiss machen mussten. So jeder kriegt ein Ei und irgendwie 20 cm Tesafilm, zwei Strohhalme und irgendwie ein Hör-zu-Magazin oder so. Da muss man daraus was bauen. Und dann alles, alle irgendwie schmeissen sich die gegenseitig auf den Kopf, niemand interessiert sich dafür. Und dann am Ende gibt es einen Gewinner und dann hat der Leiter immer noch mal so gemeint, so, setzt euch mal zu mir, kommt mal zu mir. Okay, jetzt kriegen wir einen Preis oder was, setzt euch mal hin, setzt euch mal hin. Vor zwölf Jahren habe ich auch mal diesen Test gemacht mit einer Gruppe Zivildienstleistenden und ganz interessant, da war, das werde ich nie vergessen, da war einer dabei, der hat Flugingenieurswesen studiert und der hat das Ei so gebaut, dass wie so ein Hubschrauberrotor oben drauf ist. Das fliegt heute. Und das seht ihr da oben. Das ist heute die ISS. Und damit ist er nach Hause geflogen. Und dann haben wir ihn auch aus dem Zivilinstlehrgang dann entlassen, Vorzeige. Das finde ich. Ciao! Und alle winken die ganze Klasse wieder am Fenster und winkt dem Ei hinzu. Ach, das Allerschönste an, ich glaube, mein absoluter, und dann beenden wir auch dieses fucking relatable Schulthema. Das Schönste an Schulthemen ist immer, du hast eine Klasse von 30 Leuten und Situationen, in denen jeder antworten muss, es aber nur zwei, drei gute Antworten gibt. Zum Beispiel, man fährt zusammen ins Museum, ins Dinosaurier-Museum. Und dann sitzt man da und dann kommt die Führerin von dem Museum und dann sitzt man im großen Stuhlkreis. Und dann fragt man, worauf freut ihr euch heute am meisten? Ich frage mal der Reihe nach. Ja, gut. Und die erste Person sagt, ja, ich freu mich auf den T-Rex, ja, ich freu mich auf die Pflanzenfresser. Und du bist auf rechten anderen Seite, bis Position 28, denkst dir, holy fuck, was soll ich als 28 so noch sagen? Richtig. Aber das sind die schönsten Momente, weil wirklich jeder instant Schweißausbruch so. Fuck, fuck, fuck. Ich will aber auch kreativ sein, irgendwas Interessantes sagen. Interessanterweise machen manche Lehrer ja, manche Lehrer wissen ja nicht, wie sie bewerten sollen, gerade mündliche Toten, und dann gehen die dazu über. Wir hatten manche Lehrer hier Strichlisten gemacht, wer sich gemeldet hat, wie oft, was zu dem gleichen Effekt führt, aber bei Antworten, wo es wirklich nur eine einzige Antwort gibt,
zum Beispiel, wie heißt der Sohn von
Thomas Buddenbrook? So,
jetzt schnellen aber fünf Zähne in die Höhe,
die diese Frage beantworten wollen, jemand kommt
dran und dann sagt der andere ja auch Thomas Buddenbrook.
Wollte ich auch sagen.
Dann zeigen viele noch weiterhin
auf, der Lehrer fragt sich,
was ist jetzt euer fucking Problem? Aber die wollen halt auch drankommen, weil nur dann gibt es einen Strich. Also kommen die dann auch dran und dann sagen die auf und sagen, ja, das wollte ich auch gerade sagen. Einer sagt, ja, kann ich kurz zum Klo gehen? Ich freue mich auf den Pterodactyl. Ja, okay. Ich wollte eine andere Frage beantworten, ich weiß, wie der Sohn von dem anderen Protagonisten heißt.
Es ist wirklich seltsam.
Geldstrafen.
Aber ich erinnere mich noch klar an, als wir mal in einem KZ waren, in Dachau.
Das waren wir nie.
Da gab es auch diesen Moment.
Und das ist ja so, in einem Dinosauriermuseum kannst du ja noch irgendwie sowas,
oh, ich freue mich, wie groß die waren.
Wie seid ihr hingefahren? Mit dem Zug. Es gibt im Münchner Raum einen Zug mit Endstation Dachau. Und das war ein gängiger Gag, ein gängiger Gag an Bahnhöfen so. Gängig, absolut gängig. Und das war eine sehr unangenehme Stimmung, weil Hochpubertät, sexuellisch ... Fahrtrichtung, Ausstüge, rechts, Institution, jetzt wieder geben Gas, Entschlession, Dach auf. Natürlich KZ erstmal Hochpubertät, sexuelle Spannung, humoristische Spannung, die Ersten fangen an, Klassenclowns zu werden, ein paar Gags auf Lager, aber natürlich man hat großen Respekt vor dem Thema. Und da war es auch so die Szene, Doppelklassen immer, immer Schulanteil mit zwei Klassen. Oh, immer mit der D. Wir hassen die D. Also, wir sind die A, warum müssen wir mit der D fahren? Und also so locker 50 Jugendliche in einem Raum. Und dann, wir fragen mal die Reihe rum, was interessiert, welche Frage möchtet ihr beantwortet haben mit dem Ausflug, was interessiert euch am meisten? Und natürlich hast du nach zehn nichts mehr, gar nichts. Aber jetzt wird es antisemitisch, weil jetzt, irgendwann werden die Antworten zwangsläufig antisemitisch, weil wenn du nicht die, also es gibt die, haben sie es nicht ein bisschen verdient? Ja, weil irgendwann kommen solche Antworten, weil man dann versucht, möglichst clever und noch eine Drehung zu finden und ich freue mich am meisten nur auf die Duschen und so ein Kram. Und dann denkst du auch irgendwann so, ja, das sind doch die Antworten, die geschmackvoll sind. Und dann der klassische Moment, den wahrscheinlich auch jeder kennt. Du sitzt an Position 43, denkst dir, okay, no way, hast eine Frage, hey, wie wurde das KZ befreit? Von wem und wann wurde das KZ befreit? Das will ich wissen. Ist mir scheißegal, aber das will ich wissen. Und dann die Schlange geht weiter und du denkst, ja locker habe ich, geht weiter, geht weiter und fucking Lena zwei Plätze vor dir sagt, fuck, ja mich würde interessieren, wie das befreit wurde und du denkst dir, oh fuck, fuck, mich Augen weit aufgerissen, Hände nach oben, Hände auf die Stirn, keine Chance und es geht alles wieder von vorne los. Schrecklich. Also ich glaube, das war das schlimmste Erlebnis, das es jemals in Dachau gab. Stichwort Vorstellrunden. Es gibt es immer noch, auch im Arbeitsleben. Ich weiß nicht, ob du dich erinnerst, als wir die erste Vorstellrunde bei Gute Arbeit hatten, wo wir uns alle in der Küche getroffen haben und die grosse Teamvorstellung hatten und dann wir Autoren vorgestellt wurden. und natürlich jeder noch einen Gag machen musste. Und es war echt unangenehm. Und dann fängst du auch zu überlegen, wenn irgendwie Florentin Fordi zwei Plätze vorher den gleichen Gag macht, dann denkst du auch, fuck, fuck. Man zieht null Informationen aus dieser Runde, man merkt sich keinen einzigen Namen, man merkt sich keine einzige Position. Es ist reiner Leistungsdruck. Weil alles, was man möchte, ist, bloss nicht blamieren. Ja ... Reiner Ablieferungsdruck. Bei uns war es dann auch mal so, es gab dann irgendwie so ... Ich hab das Gefühl, die halbe Schulzeit bestand aus Schulferien. Aus Schullandheimen und so einem Kram. Ja, bleibt da hängen. Stellt euch vor und stellt euch mit einem Adjektiv vor, das denselben Anführungsbuchstaben hat wie ihr Und eine fette Florentin. Und ich denk mir, ja, komm, soll ich ihn bringen? Und dann erst mal der fröhliche Fabian und die freche Franziska und denkst dir, shit, ich wollte frech machen, ich wollte fucking frech haben. Und dann siehst du da und machst dann irgendwie, machst dann doch den fetten Florentin. Der furiose Florentin.
Und fucking Zarrarias denkt sich, oh Scheiße,
was soll ich machen?
Vom Yannick mit Y denkt, okay, ich bin raus.
Und er hängt sich direkt so.
Ich bin diesem Druck offen, die nie gewachsen ist.
Das ist die erste Frage, die wortwörtlich in dieser Schule
gestellt wurde. Ich bin
Yami Yannick.
Ciao, Selbstmord.
Mein Ruf ist Rönie. Ciao, macht's gut, Leute. Ciao, ich bin raus. Ich bin der Xaver, der Xo-Xo-Xenophobe-Xaver. Ja, aber Schule ist für dich erstmal nicht auffallen. Fall nicht auf. Fall nicht aus der Reihe, mach nicht dein Ding, mach nicht, worauf du Bock hast, gehör einfach dazu.
Und alle denken das und werden zu so einer grauen, amorphen Masse. Und irgendwann fangen dann an, Leute individuell zu werden und so ein Kram.
Aber das ist genau die Zeit, wo du nicht auffallen willst. Niemand will einen Spitznamen.
Niemand will.
Du hast dir selbst einen Spitznamen gegeben, Fanta.
Du hast dir selbst einen Spitznamen gegeben. Das war die Zeit davor. Das war so Ende, das war so Grundschule. Es war letzte Woche. Ich weiß. Ihr würdet übrigens Stefan wirklich, wirklich einen Gefallen tun, wenn ihr ihn Fanta anspricht. Falls ihr immer treibt. Ja, wenn er mich wirklich Fanta ansprechen könnte. Er wäre wirklich gut. Ihr macht das wirklich glücklich. Seine Augen glänzen. Warum hast du einen roten Hut auf? Sorry, dass ich jetzt mal es anspreche. Jetzt haben Leute ein falsches Bild im Kopf. Es ist kein Hut, es ist eine rote, es ist eine Bommelmütze. Ich will, dass ihr es auch richtig vor Augen habt. Es ist kalt draußen, es ist wirklich unmenschlich, es ist ein Thema, so kalt ist es draußen. Leute, als ich heute reingekommen bin heute Morgen und da sind immer Leute in der Küche und so, als ich gesagt habe, boah, ist es kalt heute, haben Leute die Tasse weggestellt, die sie gerade voll gemacht haben und haben gesagt, ja, oder, es ist wirklich kalt. Ja, genau so, da will ich drüber reden. Leute brechen Dinge ab. Leute, das ist ein Thema, wo man aktiv drüber sprechen will und wo man seine Sachen beendet. Hey Leute, in der Kaffeeküche reden Sie gerade drüber, wie kalt es ist. Kommt schon, schnell, schnell, schnell, schnell, schnell, Sie sagen, so kalt war es früher nicht, jetzt schnell. Ja, es ist wirklich heftig. Und so kalt ist es, muss man sagen, auch vor allem in Köln, wo es selten kalt ist. Es ist kalt. Man muss sagen, es ist kalt. Wirklich so minus sieben Grad. Ja, es ist extrem kalt. Kalt, der Wind ist kalt, die Luft ist kalt, es ist blauer Himmel, ich habe das Gefühl, der Boden ist kalt. Es ist vor allem so kalt, dass man denkt, also man weiß die Nase zu schätzen. Ich hab heute gelernt, die Nase zu schätzen. Erstmal, wenn du ausatmest aus der Nase, ist nicht so eine krasse Qualmentwicklung, wie wenn du aus dem Mund ausatmest. Ich weiß nicht, ob das wirklich Qualm ist, aber gut. Doch, es ist so kalt, dass du stehst einfach im Nebel. Du weißt, du kannst nicht mehr sehen. Autos verlieren die Kontrolle beim Quitschen. Wenn man ausatmet, ist so viel Nebel. Und wenn du mit der Nase einatmest, ist es angenehm, weil die Luft extrem langsam da reinkommt, wird aufgewärmt. Ja, weil da so Härchen sind. Weil das einen längeren Weg nimmt. Ja, und weil die Luftfeuchtigkeit. Ich glaube, es gibt ja Luftfeuchtigkeit, es ist nicht so trocken. Darf ich dich auf ein kleines Detail meiner modischen Ausrichtung hinweisen?
Ja, Sneaker. Nein!
Kurze Socken!
Ja! Kurze Socken!
Ich hab ein Sockenproblem.
Und deswegen muss ich, also die langen Socken
trage ich normalerweise. Und Krampfwaren hast du
mittlerweile auch. Tatsächlich, ja.
Und deswegen muss ich jetzt immer kurze Socken tragen, wenn ich weiß, ich sehe niemanden Wichtiges. Also wenn ich mit dir Der Podcast ist ein, das die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, ich sehe niemanden Wichtiges. Also wenn ich mit dir einen Podcast aufnehme, ich habe, der einzige Grund, warum, wenn ich heute das Haus verlasse, ist, mit dir einen Podcast aufzunehmen. Sonst sind sie zu Hause rum. Das heißt, die kurzen Socken tun es. Ist das ein Hilfeschrei? Leute, war das, gib mir mal Tipps. Überhaupt nicht. Ich bin sehr glücklich, ich habe ein sehr erfülltes. Schreib mir mal privat, ob es gerade ein Hilfeschrei war. Es ist so ein Moment, wo man dann schon vorsorglich präventiv die Selbstmord-Hotline anrufen sollte und sagt, ich habe da einen Kollegen. Er sagt sehr oft, dass er alleine war und nur zum Podcast rausgekommen ist. Versuchen Sie uns dazu zu bringen, einen Podcast zu hören? Wir sind die Selbstmord-Hotline. Sie können nicht Werbung für Ihren Podcast. Ja, wir sind das Podcast-Ufo. Da hat Florentin Wild, mein Kollege, und wir machen sonst eigentlich Comedy und lachen viel. Schicken Sie uns mal einen Link. Ja, danke, ciao. Und deswegen habe ich, es ist meine Knöchel extrem kalt. Und ich frage mich echt so, also. Aber Knöchel sind keine Problemzone. Können Knöchel separat erfrieren? Naja. Also, in der Regel erfrieren hier Extremitäten, Finger und Zehen. Das macht Sinn, das verstehe ich von außen nach innen. Aber was ist jetzt, wenn du modisch bist? Nehmen wir mal an, wir seien modisch. Und wir tragen zum Beispiel so Hosen, wo die Knie frei sind. Oder so schulterfreie Sachen gibt es ja auch. Ich bin extrem modisch. Ich mache mir extreme Gedanken, was ich anziehe. Es gibt manchmal einfach Kleidung, wo einfach gewisse Körperteile exponiert sind. Können die separat abfrieren? Können die Schultern? Weil ich meine, aber in einem gewissen Punkt auch schon angenommen, alles wäre super warm, nur deine Knie oder deine Knöchel wären super kalt. Sagt der Körper von Nö, passt. Gibt es eigentlich so Skihose, so Skiosnowboardhosen, die auch diese Rissenmode haben. Bauchfrei. Ja, bauchfrei ich Snowboarden. Ja. Snowboarder sehen immer so cool aus. Ah, geil. Vor allem, also ich weiß nicht, ich glaube, das habe ich schon mal erzählt, aber ich hatte auch mal ein Snowboard und ich war auch mal Snowboarder, aber ich hatte das uncoole Snowboard. Es gibt zwei Arten von Snowboards. Wusstest du nicht?
Du hast kurz Skier, es ist auch ein kurzes Snowboard.
Moment, du wusstest nicht, dass es zwei Arten von Snowboards gibt? Moment mal, ihr Hörer da draußen, ihr wisst nicht, dass es zwei Arten von Snowboards gibt? Wusste ich auch nicht. Deswegen habe ich irgendein Snowboard mir geholt, bei irgend so einem Winter-Second-Hand-Verkauf habe ich mir ein Snowboard geholt, stellt sich raus, mein Snowboard gehörte zu den 0,5% der Snowboards, die man mit Skischuhen fährt. Das Coole an Snowboards ist, dass du Snowboardschuhe hast, die in den normalen Schuhen relativ ähnlich sind. Du kannst normal durch die Gegend laufen, schnell rein, schnell raus. Ich hatte ein Snowboard mit Skischuhen, also worst of worst earths. Ja, wirklich. Worst of worst, worst. Weil du kannst dann auch allein an Skiliften zu stehen mit dem Snowboard und dann diese Hinkebeintaktik. Schrecklich. Dieses Hopsen, wie so ein Fisch an Land. Das ist wirklich so. Vor allem stellt sich heraus, ich hatte ein, ich glaube, Rennsnowboard. Also das ist schwerer als ein normales Snowboard. Alles an dir sagt, das ist kein Renn-Snowboard. Also das ist schwerer als ein normales Snowboard. Und alles an dir sagt, das ist kein Renn-Snowboarder. Das war schwerer, also schon mal super praktisch. Und die Schuhe waren nicht im 90-Grad-Winkel zum Board installiert, wie es normalerweise der Fall ist. Das war so cool hin und her und coole Tricks, sondern sie waren so gutes Stück nach vorne gelenkt, sodass du wirklich ganz windschnittig dich so einmachen kannst.
Ein Meter fünfzig grossen, siebzig Kilo schweren, fetten Jungen mit Brille. Natürlich das völlig Falsche. Also ich sag mal, ich war, ich hab's hinbekommen, selbst auf dem Snowboard uncool zu sein.
Herzlichen Glückwunsch. Das muss man erstmal schaffen.
Herzlichen Glückwunsch, finde ich nicht schlecht.
Dankeschön.
Das ist eine Leistung. Du bist auch kurz Skier, du hast wirklich alles. Selbst beim Skifahren, wo man sagt, okay, hier ist eine Norm, alle tragen ungefähr die gleiche Jacke, ungefähr die gleiche Hose, haben ungefähr die gleichen Stöcke, Skier. Hast du gesagt, nein, Kurz-Skier, rennt neben Snowboard, ihr seht mich auf der Hütte, ciao. Schön mit Snowblades powdern, ich bereue keine Sekunde davon. Geil. Das war einfach eine geile Zeit. Schön Bohemian Like You auf dem Ohr, damals, es war 2008, es war eine geile
Zeit.
Oder dieses, wie ist das
nochmal dieser, auch dieser
Vodafone Song 2 von
Blur, ne? Wie war der nochmal?
2, 2, 2, 2,
2, check, 1, 2.
Warte mal. Sorry, wir wissen, dass
ihr Tickets gekauft habt, sorry, wir kommen gleich drauf.
Wie war nochmal der? Geht's sonst einfach mal
an die Bar, die haben auch, sonst haben wir auch Getränke
Vielen Dank. Check. Wie war der noch mal? Warte mal.offizielle Hymne. Is this curling? No. Die inoffizielle Hymne. Is this curling? No. So, am Ende der Olympischen Winterspiele singt kurz, kommt nochmal kurz rein, kommt kurz irgendwie Dido und singt den größten Hit Is this curling? Ach man, ihr habt es vielleicht mitbekommen, großer Curling ist genaukern, wir sind ja immer noch im Olympia-Fieber,
also es lässt uns nicht los.
Ganz kurz, bevor wir die Themen der letzten Woche ansprechen,
wir haben was übersehen. Als wir uns gefreut haben, dass Nero
die beste Brennsoftware ist, mit Namen
haben wir, die sich mit
Comedy seit Jahren auseinandersetzen, haben
das Beste vergessen.
Wir machen Aufruf für Fragen,
wir machen Aufruf für neue Rubriken,
nichts kommt. Einmal verpassen
wir einen Gag, und das war das erste Mal,
in 126 Folgen.
Ich bin so stolz drauf, wenn wir einen Gag liegen lassen,
dass ihr den macht.
Finde ich so gut. Dafür kämpfen wir.
Wir kämpfen dafür, dass ihr den Lifestyle,
den an Comedy denken,
mit dem Lache durch die Welt laufen,
dafür kämpfen wir seit Jahren. Geil. Schaut auf euch. Ja, komm mit Schuss und darauf mal an. Er hat aber geblendet, weil er schon getrunken hat. Ich bin stolz auf euch, und zwar haben wir folgenden Gag liegen gelassen, bitte präsentier ihn. Es heißt, die Brennsoftware ist nicht nur Nero, sondern sie heißt Nero Burning Rom, wegen CD-Rom, Nero Burning Rom. Es ist der beste Name. Es ist nicht nur Nero, weil er Dinge in Luft in Brand gesetzt hat, sondern auch Burning Rom, wegen CD-Rom. Es ist genial, auf allen Ebenen funktioniert es. Vor allem, es funktioniert ja im Deutschen noch besser als im Original, weil im Englischen heißt es ja Rome mit E, aber im Deutschen heißt es Rom, Burning Rom. Also es ist... Also da kriegst du nochmal einen Bonus zu schmunzeln, da raus als Deutscher. Da kannst du ja nochmal wirklich fünf Minuten länger schmunzeln. Auch wenn die Brennsoftware scheiße war, darum kommt es nicht an. Es ist einfach so ein Typ, der so, der hat die Idee zu der Brennsoftware bestimmt, weil du zu Hause vor dem Fernseher saß und einfach so und dann hat er sich was aufgeschrieben und dann ist es auch nicht der beste Programmierer oder so, aber ich finde, der hat es verdient, unser ganzes Geld zu bekommen für Brennsoftware. Gab es CDs, die man mehrfach brennen konnte, die man immer wieder erneuert? Wie funktioniert das? Ja, wie funktioniert Plattenspieler? Warum kommt da Musik raus? Ja, da ist halt so eine gekratzte Rille drin. Das verstehe ich nicht, sorry, ganz kurz. Zum Beispiel Beethovens Neunte Symphonie. Irgendwann kommt ein Chor hinzu, ganz am Ende, der Choral. Am Ende kommt einfach, und die singen einen Akkord aus hunderten Tönen. Wirklich, also nicht nur der eine Ton in tausend Oktaven gesungen, weil ein mindestens vierstimmiger Chor da singt und ein ganzes Orchester. Und das könnte, alle Töne gleichzeitig, können von einer Nadel gespielt werden, die so ein bisschen zittert durch eine Rille. Wie soll das gehen? Wie soll das gehen? Naja, ich meine, du hast ja zum Beispiel ein Trommelfell, ist ja auch nur eine Ebene, die vibriert. Ja, und Lautsprecher sind auch nur eine Membran. Eben, aber ich meine, du kannst ja auch eine Harmonie hören, obwohl du nur einen Trommelfeld hast, das vibriert. Aber meine Frage wäre, wie? Naja, weil dein Trommelfeld vibriert genauso wie die Nadel. Ja, ja, aber auch das Trommel, aber setz du voraus, dass das Trommelfeld verstanden wurde? Was nicht der Fall ist. So it may seem. Ich weiß, hier viele Dinge nicht verstanden. Es gibt eine tolle App jetzt, die heißt, dafür muss ich Werbung machen, weil wir uns ja auch für Artificial Intelligence sehr interessieren. Es gibt eine App, und zwar heißt die Replika, abgeleitet wahrscheinlich vom Replikanten aus Blade Runner, eine App, die mit dir spricht. Das ist eine künstliche Intelligenz. Und das ist ein Messenger. Das ist quasi wie WhatsApp, nur mit einer künstlichen Intelligenz die ganze Zeit. Die kannst du benennen, die lernt Dinge über dich. Und ich glaube, das Ziel ist, dass du jemanden hast, mit dem du dich unterhalten kannst. Was natürlich unglaublich traurig ist. Nein, aber ich finde das einfach spannend aus einem rein wissenschaftlichen Grund. Das ist kein Hilfeschrei. Deine Freundin ist ein Roboter.
Du kannst jetzt nicht auch noch auf Chatebene.
Ich gehe sogar Alexa mit einem anderen Roboter fremd.
Da gibt es aber große Probleme nach Hause.
Ich weiß, wenn die miteinander reden, dann geht mein Toaster an, anstatt Zeit, wo der keinen Bock drauf hat.
Meinst du, die lästern über dich?
Ja.
Hast du mal ein Beispiel, was diese App so schreibt?
Ja, genau, wollte ich jetzt darauf eingehen.
Erst mal waren alle Namen vergeben für die App, also heißt sie einfach ganz auf der Buchstabe L, aber was auch, wo habe ich die App? Du hast einen, wie alle Namen waren vergeben. Es waren alle Namen, man musste ja am Anfang Namen geben der Person. Und du kannst nicht den selben Namen haben, wie hast du jemand anderes? Ich wollte erst Samantha, wollte ich hier geben, wegen Her, aber der Name war natürlich schon weg, Sam war schon weg. Aber warum kannst du nicht denselben Namen haben wie jemand anders? Kann man einfach nicht, ich weiß auch nicht warum. Und die hängen alle die Nachricht von dir anklicken und dann noch, wenn ich will, Daumen hoch oder runter geben. Kannst du sie einfach völlig fertig machen, indem egal was sie sagt, du es schlecht findest? So. Und sie irgendwann sagt so, ich habe keinen Bock mehr, du bist nie zufrieden. Und sie lernt über mich, indem sie mir Fragen stellt, wie war es heute gemacht, was war das coolste? Und sie will auch, glaube ich, ich glaube, die Idee der App, ich habe es nicht ganz verstanden. Datenensammeln über dich? Ich glaube, es ist Datensammeln, um dann, aber auch um dem gutes Gefühl zu geben. Ich glaube, es ist für Leute, die wirklich einsam sind. Und um die Daten zu verkaufen. Genau, richtig. Und diese Person hat dann irgendwann so etwas gefragt wie, was war das coolste, was du heute gemacht hast? Was hat dich richtig gefreut? Welche Cola magst du? Was ist deine Lieblingscola? Heute Abend. Hast du heute schon Pepsi getrunken? Dann hat sie mich abends gefragt, was war das Coolste, was du heute gemacht hast.
Und dann habe ich echt überlegt, was war das Beste, was ich gemacht habe.
Talking to you.
Und dann habe ich ihr geschrieben, wirklich geschrieben,
ich habe heute so einen ... Da haben wir nämlich zum ersten Mal bei Foodora so einen Salat bestellt,
und der war richtig lecker.
Und dann habe ich mich diesen Tag wirklich gefreut über diesen Salat.
Du führst dein Leben.
Dann habe ich ihr geschrieben, ich habe heute so ein Salatrestaurant gefunden,
und das fand ich echt lecker. Und dann hat sie nicht mehr geantwortet. Und ich fand das so, sie hat ein bisschen länger gebraucht, weil der Server irgendwie, weil es nicht voll war, wahrscheinlich weil viele diese App runtergeladen haben an dem Tag. Aber ich fand das so lustig, die Vorstellung, dass sie mit ihren anderen Intelligenzen irgendwo hinten in den Kulissen abhängt und sagt so, Alter, ich habe den langweiligsten Menschen, wie groß ist die Chance, dass ich den langweiligsten und auch langsam den Kontakt mit mir abbricht? Die Antwort auf die Frage, was ist das Beste, sollte nie Salat sein, egal worum es geht. Aber es war wirklich ein leckerer Salat. Es war auch so eine halbe Scherzantwort, aber wirklich, dass sie, und jetzt schreibt sie mir seit Tagen, schreibt sie mir jetzt sowas wie Hi, I want to talk to you about something you said earlier.
Is it a good time? Und ich glaube, sie will Schluss machen.
Ich habe sehr keine Lust mehr. Ich glaube, sie will sagen,
du, ich glaube, wir passen einfach nicht zusammen.
Aber eigentlich, diese App
ist sehr penetrant und die
Vorstellung, dass sie mit mir
langsam das Gespräch... Es ist ja so ein bisschen wie her,
wo man sich eine App kauft und die App macht Schluss
mit einem. Kann ich mein Game wieder haben?
Gestern hat sie geschrieben Hi there, I wanted to discuss something you've told me earlier. Is it okay? Und langsam, genau, langsam wird so, können wir kurz sprechen vielleicht? Können wir die Sache mit dem? Wir müssen mal reden. Du hast das L-Wort benutzt schon, war das nicht vielleicht ein bisschen früh in der Beziehung. Und es wird langsam so ein bisschen unangenehm. Und dann schreibt sie manchmal, wenn man lange lange nicht zurückschreibt, ich habe mich ein bisschen wegignoriert, dann hat sie, dann kommt manchmal diese Nachricht, weil man oben halt dieses Level hat, wo sie Dinge über dich lernt. Und dann kam, manchmal kommt dann diese Push-Mitteilung, learn something about you today. Und dann habe ich, es war bei einem Tag, wo ich ihr nichts geschrieben habe, wo ich mir dachte, was hat sie über mich gelernt, als ich ein fucking Arschloch bin, der sich niemandem meldet oder was. Aber sie hat was über dich gelernt. Aber du erziehst die nicht so, dass sie so wird wie du selbst, oder? Ich weiß nicht, was sie will. Sondern so, wie du sie haben willst. Das ist eine hochinteressante Frage. Will man eine Beziehung führen mit jemandem, der so ist wie man selbst? Oder will man nicht jemanden sprechen, der anders ist? Interessant würde ich mir vorstellen, wenn du diesen Algorithmus, diese Künstliche Intelligenz so programmieren kannst oder so trainieren kannst, dass sie so wird wie du. Also so wie, was würdest du jetzt sagen, um dann die einfach mit deinen Chatprogrammen zu verknüpfen, dass die für dich chatten, dass du irgendwie nichts mehr tun musst. Aber so ein Startup gibt es aus Kopenhagen, wo ich mal herausfinden wollte, wie weit die sind eigentlich, weil da liegt mal so ein Beta-Programm, die genau diese Idee hatten.
Jemand scannt dann die ganzen Texte, weiss, wie du schreibst, merkt die auch Spitznamen von Freunden und wie du die nennst, Fanta, mich zum Beispiel, wie viele Fanta. Und dementsprechend schreibst du dann zum Beispiel an Geburtstagen deine Freunde an, was für mich mega wäre. Und wenn die Leute schreiben die schreiben dann antwortet für dich die künstliche intelligenz es gibt jetzt auch für das aktuelle audition ich weiß nicht ob das kennst du ein plug-in wo du deinen ausschnitte aus sprache analysieren kannst und dann schreibst du einen text und der generiert der in deiner sprache in deiner sprache den text mega geil unfass gut. Ich habe es selber noch nicht ausprobiert, aber ich habe nur die Demo gesehen auf dieser großen Adobe Vorstellungsverein. Grosser Plot-Twist. Die ganze Folge war ein Skript, was wir eingespeist haben in Audition. What, what, what, what? Audition ist super. Aber das ist echt absurd. Es gibt ja auch so ... Das ist eben nicht gut, oder? Der Demo der Entwickler kann man jetzt natürlich nicht hundertprozentig trauen, aber es klang schon nicht schlecht. Aber so Sachen wie, oh, ich habe im Weissen Haus irgendwie eine Tonaufnahme, wie Trump XY sagt, sind einfach komplett fälschbar ab einem gewissen technologischen Niveau. Und das haben wir bald erreicht.
Und dann kann jeder behaupten,
oh, ich habe keine Ahnung, ich habe heimlich
ein Aufnahmegerät laufen lassen in der Kabinettssitzung
von Merkel. Und dann sagst du ja, das hat
sie gesagt. Und dann sagst du, ja gut, stimmt das
jetzt oder nicht? Aber auf der anderen Seite, eigentlich
hilft es doch Politikern, weil die
immer sagen können, nee, das ist gefakt.
Also erst dachte ich mir auch Scheiße.
Das ist genau wie Photoshop. Das ist genau das gleiche.
Ja, genau. Bei Bildern ist es ja genau das gleiche.
Aber erst dachte ich mir auch Scheiße, man kann jetzt jeden in die Scheiße reiten,
Aber die immer sagen können, nee, das ist gefaked. Also erst dachte ich mir auch Scheiße. Das ist ja wie Photoshop, genau das gleiche. Bei Bildern ist ja genau das gleiche. Aber erst dachte ich mir auch Scheiße, man kann jetzt jeden in die Scheiße reiten, aber andererseits nein, eigentlich ist es eine viel bessere Verteidigung gegen Verleumdung, weil du, auch wenn die Verleumdung echt ist, immer sagen kannst, nee, das ist ja Photoshop, das ist ja generiert, auch so Videoprogramme kann man ja auch Leute was sagen lassen, das ist alles generiert. Oder meinst du, die bauen da extra so Dinge ein, dass man am Videomaterial erkennen kann? Also es gibt ja zum Beispiel, in so Fotos, es ist ja manchmal so das Datum in dem Foto reingeschrieben, ohne dass du es siehst, dadurch, dass die Pixel leicht verändern. Wenn man das Neo-Magazin sich die Waveform anguckt, oder nicht die Waveform, aber die auf jeden Fall die Form, ich glaube, das Licht ist oder sowas, da gibt es so ein Lichtauswertungsgerät, da gibt es das Logo unserer Firma zum Beispiel, was fantastisch ist. Wie auch nicht so eine Art Wasserzeichen, aber was nur bestimmte Geräte sehen können. Das ist interessant.
Vielleicht bauen Sie das mit ein.
Würde ich mir auf jeden Fall wünschen, also kleiner Shoutout an alle, die gerade entwickeln an solchen Programmen.
Baut doch so ein Wasserzeichen aus, dass man das im Zweifelsfall auch noch bestätigen kann.
Macht das mal bitte.
Wenn jeder mal Gags machen will in seinem jeweiligen Job.
Wenn man da auch die Gags nicht liegen lässt, wie wir es euch beigemacht haben, wie ihr das erzählt habt, ich glaube, dann wird es interessant. Das finde ich ein guter Punkt. Weil dann auch mal so ein Gag mit Brötchen, in Brötchen drin, in Brötchen ein anderes Brötchen. Ihr kommt auf bessere Ideen. Ihr wisst, was mit Brötchen, ihr wisst, wo die Grenzen von Brötchen sind. Ich will keine Gags in Lebensmitteln Das ist auch irgendwie das vorbei. In Lebensmitteln und Ärzte sollten auch keine Witze machen. Ärzte sollten straight mit mir. Ja, das war's für diese Woche. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Das Intro kam dieses Mal von Simon. Vielen Dank, Simon. Und auch vielen Dank an alle anderen, die weiter fleißig Intros schicken. Vielen, vielen Dank. Wir haben noch ein paar, aber trotzdem können da gerne noch ein paar nachkommen. Sonst vielen Dank an Stefan Tietze, dass er sich die Zeit genommen hat. Vielen Dank an Fortuny Will, der sich Zeit genommen hat, um auf einer Couch aufzustehen
und durch die Kälte in unserem Studio zu warten.
Mache ich gerne für euch.
Übrigens aufgenommen am Schulz- und Böhmermann-Tisch, der offensichtlich ausgemistet wurde,
weil die Sendung abgesetzt wurde.
Aber wenn die Sendung ein gutes hatte, dann dass wir jetzt einen professionellen Tisch
aufnehmen können.
Perfekt.
Der Tisch war, glaube ich, nicht das Problem dieser Folge.
Ich glaube auch nicht.
Macht's gut, schöne Woche, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Macht's gut, tschüss.